Nếu gió, bột chính trị yêu cầu các cấp quý tổ chức đàn thực hiện có tốt một số sẻ
pháp xây dần gơi trẻ chính xác luật phá của trời. Nhanh thú út sử dụng đại ngộ
lối với những cán bộ thực sự tại năng xuất sắc đáp ứng yêu cầu và chình đất nước trong kỳn
miệng mới. Cùng về đó tạo lập mùi trường làm việc công khai mình bạng dân chủ
loàn kết hỗ trợ thình thèng cạnh tranh ngày mai. Gưa thể hiện sự tôn trọng,
li cầu cán bộ có thể năng, gưa tạo có vội dụ kia nể cán bộ tận tâm cộng
và pháp xây dần. Về thị trẻ, bôi chính trị yêu cầu tiếp tục cuộc thế hoa các trụ trường
li quý tổ đàn về thu hút trọng dụng người có tài năng và các cơ quan trong hệ thống chính trị.
Nên cầu hiệu quả công các cán bộ. Nên sách nhìn lưỡa sạm vụ chỉ khoảng người phần trăm
tổ của ý tình lần. Để thực hiện chính xác thu hút trọng dụng cho phép quy động thêm 1 lực sá hội,
các nhà qua học chuyên gia nhà quả lý sỏi có thể được tuyển dụng đặt cách không qua thị tuyển.
Về tãi ngộ, cán bộ, chuyên gia nhà qua học lâu ngành được hưởng phụ cấp tăng thêm
tối thiệu các trọng phần trọng liệu hàng tháng trọng năm năm.
Sình viên xuất sát được hưởng 1 trọng năm 2019 phụ cấp tăng thêm.
chính xác mới thể hiện quyết tâm của đàn về nhận lưỡa.
Trong việc tạo mua trường cầy mở, công bằng lui dựng và trọng dụng in tài cho sự phát triển về nơi.